the media can't get enough of Trump aide
Sam Nunn Berg social media goes crazy
and intersectionality makes people even
crazier than usual I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
so cable news yesterday was a wild
thanks to Sam fun Berg
I mean sam nunn berg of course the
former Trump aide who decided to go on
every TV network and basically vomit his
thoughts everywhere and the media just
kept featuring and we'll talk about all
of that plus I don't get to the West
Virginia teachers strike which is really
kind of avoided the major news which is
kind of amazing I also want to talk
about something brewing inside left-wing
circles and that is really ugly and I'm
not just talking about the
intersectionality that animates college
campuses I'm talking about something
beyond that we'll get to all of that
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at quip so quip is the
best place to go if you are looking for
a solid electric toothbrush and the
reason the quip is better than other
electric toothbrushes is it packs just
the right amount of vibration into a
slimmer designed at a fraction of the
cost of bulkier traditional electric
brushes well your teeth health actually
matters a lot in fact it connects pretty
solidly according to research with your
heart help and there's a reason why you
need an electric toothbrush as opposed
to just a manual toothbrush this
toothbrush from equip works better than
any of the others and it's easy to
travel with as well so I'm on the road a
lot unfortunately and that means that
I've got the quip electric toothbrush
with me fortunately all the time these
are not gonna carry alone that around
that big bulky charger thing it has
guiding pulses alerting you when to
switch sides making brushing at the
right amount effortless it also comes
with the mount that suctions writes your
mirror a nun sticks to use as a cover
for a hygienic travel anywhere whether
it's going in your gym bag or your
carry-on and because the thing that
cleans your mouth should also be clean
that means they have a subscription plan
and it refreshes your brush on a dentist
recommended schedule they delivered new
brush heads every three months for just
five bucks including free shipping
worldwide so you never have to worry
about whether you've been using that
same brush head for three years now and
it's disgusting right now equip send
something to you every three months you
just pop on the new head on equip and
you're ready to go clip is backed by a
network of over 10,000 dental
professionals and there is a reason wide
whip starts right now
at 25 bucks and if you go to get quip
comm slash Shapiro get quip comm slash
Shapiro you get your first free pill
refill pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
absolutely free it get quick calm slash
Shapiro GE t qu IP comm slash Shapiro
used that slash appear so they know we
sent you again it is the best toothbrush
in the business and they will send you
these refills that make it really easy
to ensure that your toothbrush is clean
equip is just 25 bucks and if it
quip calm / appear you get that first
refill pack absolutely free and lets
them know that we say you okay so
yesterday the media went totally nuts
over a guy named san nunberg so who is
sam nunn berg so I had a conversation
one time with Santa number get was
shortly after sam nunn Bergen and fired
by the Trump campaign and he called me
up for some reason I can't remember what
it was and he was to say it to say it
mildly a kooky fellow who exactly is Sam
number well the Washington Post who says
nunberg was an early member of Trump's
political team when the moguls potential
candidacy was seen mostly as a stunt in
2014 as Trump continued a long-running
flirtation with higher office nunberg
was at his side BuzzFeed says quote he
comes on a bit strong as you know
according to Roger stone right Roger
stone is a woman more disgusting
political operatives in the business
because I mean within a week of my
meeting him he was going around telling
people I was his mentor he's got clips
but as they say when men Berg is 36
years old and he picked up a law degree
from Toro College in 2009 apparently
according to BuzzFeed his first foray
into presidential campaigning came in
2007 when he worked as a volunteer for
the Romney campaign while attending law
school and he was put in charge of
organizing turnout for the New York City
GOP straw poll and he helped pull up an
upset win for Romney over Rudy Giuliani
he then went to work for the American
Center for Law and Justice which is a
Christian conservative Legal Foundation
run by Jay Sekulow who works for Trump
right now and of course he has made the
rounds in the media he was ousted in the
middle of the last campaign by the Trump
campaign the campaign apparently thought
that he was he was a destructive person
helped Hicks said quote he's a highly
self-destructive individual who makes
routine calls begging for his job back
this is the interview of a desperate
person who is trying to hang on and stay
relevant
the Trump campaign downgraded him to
low-level part-time consultants at the
time of his firing his first meeting
with Trump apparently is on tape this is
from when he was a kid and apparently he
met Trump at a WWE event which is
perfectly fitting here is tape from that
time Donald Trump invited the young
somnom book right into the heart of the
action
we were sitting like behind Trump and he
had us move to the first row and another
section and it was actually funny
because I ended up getting on the video
for Wrestlemania with my father we were
doing like the bushwacker so there is
sam nunn Berg very young Trump political
advisor and apparently he was sued
during the last election cycle Trump
sued him for like ten million dollars
claiming he broke a confidentiality
agreement or at least threatened to sue
him so yeah sam nunn Berg is a colorful
character say the least well he's now
being investigated by the Muller
investigation because the Moller
investigation is talking to every single
person ever including they haven't
talked to me but I think I may be the
only person in America they've left to
talk to so they want to talk to Sam Nunn
Berg so nunberg decides that it's
worthwhile to go on every television
show he can possibly find and go kind of
crazy so he goes on MSNBC and he
explains that if Muller wants to
interview him he's not going to do the
interview in fact he doesn't mind being
sent to jail no big deal so it starts
off with this at MSNBC if they're trying
to build a case against Roger I'm not
gonna be part of it I'm not Roger didn't
do anything
Roger didn't do anything except get
treated like crap by Donald Trump the
president you keep saying you don't
think there'll be a consequence what if
the quality for that is going to jail
Sam you're not gonna send me to jail you
know what mr. Muller if he wants to send
me to jail he could send me to jail and
then and then I'll laugh about it and I
don't make a bigger spectacle that I am
on your TV show right now well sir I
don't know what they're gonna do okay
there was a woman named Susan mcdougal
who during the Obama administration
refused to testify and she ended up
going to jail so this would not be the
first time that somebody who's refused
to testify or talk to the FBI and
they've ended up in jail and then it
gets even worse own unbirth apparently
was on CNN Jake Tapper and he actually
starts asking Jake Tapper whether he
should cooperate with Muller so he's
just going crazy live on TV he called
him to every major television show he
called into New York City one yesterday
here he is with Jake Tapper and look at
the incredulity on tappers base and we
want to hear you cooperate should I
spend 80 hours comes over my emails
shake if it were me I would I mean it's
just
asking my opinion just because it sounds
like a pain but he is the special
counsel and he does have every email I
talked to Steve and Roger stone eight
tons a day do you know what a new well I
do I go well I do I have to life and
special prosecutors are not fair I guess
I would I would cooperate were me but
you know I'm a different breed of cat
Jeffords puzzled by life right here and
then sad number calls into another show
and he explains that President Trump
really didn't go far enough during the
campaign the president Trump should have
had Bill Clinton's alleged in an alleged
illegitimate black child at the debate
this is him calling into MSNBC and
talking with Katy tur wasn't some smart
idea that we had for us to be fired and
then we were to get the emails to Russia
if Roger and me were there Katy we would
have had the Benghazi parents there at
the first debate we would have had Bill
Clinton's illegitimate black child there
at the second debate and we would have
had the women there okay so he was just
going wild on TV yesterday call Sarah
Huckabee Sanders a fat slob he suggests
that there's something there to the
Trump Russia investigation says he's not
going to talk to Muller but he thinks
that there's something going on with the
Trump Russia investigation he thinks
that term probably colluded with Russia
here's nunberg yesterday saying that Lou
Dobbs and Jeanine Pirro and Sean Hannity
are gonna be very embarrassed when all
of the Trump brushes stuff comes out and
by the way you're gonna be fine when it
comes out what he did but people like
Sean Hannity Lou Dobbs Jimmy and Piero
they're gonna have to be they're gonna
be very embarrassed yes yes so the big
question here was is Sam number the
crazy person and that's what everybody
who's watching yesterday's watching this
go on and they were thinking is this
person a crazy person and if he is a
crazy person is it moral to put a crazy
person on TV just to get President Trump
and you can see that members of the
media themselves people who are
interviewing him are suggesting that
he's either drunk or high or crazy on TV
yesterday ari Melbourne over at MSNBC
actually asked Sam Nunn Berg if he is if
he's feeling stressed out because he
says people are worried about you Sam
you and I have both been around these
types of situations these types of
probes they can be very stressful even
for people who are completely innocent
did nothing wrong it can be stressful
how are you holding up and do you want
to take more time to think this through
could you change your mind I'm not gonna
answer something so why does this this
is so ridiculous I'm not gonna give them
every email I had with Steve bandana
Roger stone I communicate with them
every day and are you are you feeling
okay you feeling stressed out like this
no and I'm feeling kind of I want to see
what mr. Miller does it's never been
done before okay and then he goes on
Erin Burnett on sienna era Burnett says
you smell like you are drunk on the air
right now like there's an actual thing
that happened on TV yesterday you know
I've or you're sitting very close to me
yeah we talked earlier about what people
in the White House were saying about you
yeah I've know whether you you were you
were drinking or on drugs or whatever
they were what had happened today I'm
talking to you yeah I have smelled
alcohol well you have another drink so
that's not no and then he says but he is
not anti depressant so here is the big
question okay there are two big
questions one does this guy have
anything useful to say the answer seems
to be no number it doesn't have anything
useful to say so the question becomes
why are the media having him on and
there's really a larger question which
is do the media have a responsibility
not to put people on TV who are
humiliating themselves and making
reality TV show spectacles of themselves
and this is a real open question because
is nunberg is it their job to to
actually not put him on the air if he's
drunk or if he's crazy so I would say
the Erin Burnett does the worst job here
because she actually apparently thinks
he's drunk presumably if an Obama
official walked in completely drunk off
his butt and walked into the CNN studios
security would be called they wouldn't
put him on the air so if Erin Burnett
actually thought that Sam Nunn Berg was
drunk or crazy or off his rocker why put
him on the air and the answer is because
all these people in the media think that
Sam Nunn Berg is going to suddenly drop
the bomb about president Trump or
because they think that it's humiliating
to the Trump administration to have once
had somebody like Sam Nunn Berthe
working for them so on the one hand you
have to say that the media their bias
their attempts to get Trump have gone
too far there are a lot of members of
the media or so interested in getting
Trump or he will awaiting trunk that
they're willing to violate their own
journalistic standards over at Axios the
journalists there Jim VandeHei
particularly is ripping into other
members of the media
this is just spectacle that there is no
news value to this whatsoever you're
putting on somebody who's clearly having
a mental breakdown on national TV and
you're doing so for the ratings and
because you hate President Trump and
that wouldn't be a shock that wouldn't
be a shock I mean when you look at the
media's desperation to get Trump it
really has reached fever pitch I mean
they are now reporting on things like
CNN now traveled to Thailand they sent
somebody to Thailand to dig up clues
about Trump
okay so first last month the network
actually sent a reported
saint-petersburg to literally dig around
in a dumpster looking for leads about
president Trump and now they sent a
reporter to Bangkok to speak with a
prostitute who claims that she has goods
on the Trump camps alleged collusion
with Russia according to grey being calm
the woman her name is Anastasia by
shukhevich who's also described as a sex
coach is currently in prison and hopes
that America will offer her Asylum in
exchange for her story so CNN promptly
sent a reporter over there his name is
Ivan Watson he met with the woman in
reported quote she is she described
herself as a seductress this woman
claims to have evidence of Russian
meddling in the u.s. election the
question is this a desperate ploy to get
out of jail
or as her friend claims is this young
woman truly in danger because she knows
too much it's a CNN has heiped
everything that is possible the hype
about Trump and Russia obviously and
that's pretty damning stuff when it
comes to why they're having people like
same number on TV I don't know that
that's the whole story don't I want to
be fair to CNN I want to be fair to
MSNBC you know explain in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Dollar Shave Club so
dollarshaveclub.com the folks who will
make give you everything you need to
feel look and smell your best it's not
just that they have the best razors in
the business though they do it's not
just that they have the magical fame dr.
Carver's at shea butter they also have
body wash they have shampoo they have
toothpaste and of course those best
razors that you have ever used those are
the razors that shave my beautiful neck
each and every evening I shave at night
so that when I get up in the morning I'm
ready to do the show certainly anyway so
go to Dollar Shave Club right now and
you get a special deal Dollar Shave Club
for just 5 bucks with Free Shipping
you'll get a 6 blade executive razor
plus trial sizes of shave butter body
cleanser and one wipe Charlies those are
the magical butt wipes they keep those
blades coming for a few bucks more per
month get yours right now
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen when you
try that travel size kit you'll know
whether you like it or not and you will
I promise
Shave Club calm at /bin that's
dollarshaveclub.com / been for just five
bucks again you get the fruit plus free
shipping you get six blade executive
razor plus those trial sizes of the shea
butter the body cleanser the one web
charli's you don't have to go to the
drugstore anymore for your soap for your
shampoo for the razors for any of that
stuff instead you can just sit at home
and wait for the Dollar Shave Club
package to arrive which it will and it
will be spectacular and you will smell
great and you will look great that's
just the way Dollar Shave Club work
style shave club calm slash men and and
you get our special deal plus the slash
gun lets them know that we sent you okay
so obviously the media have an agenda
with regard to president Trump and that
agenda is is pretty obvious now with
that said is there something to be said
for the media not actually being
supremely responsible for what Sam Nunn
Berg did here so at the Atlantic McKay
Coppins who has been following Sam Nunn
work for a long time as a reporter over
the Atlantic used to be a BuzzFeed he
has a long piece here about what Sam
Nunn Berg did was actually on purpose so
it says it was just after 8:00 p.m. on
Monday night and the suddenly famous ham
nunberg had phoned me from Dorian's Red
Hand restaurant a yuppie hangout on
Manhattan's Upper East Side where he was
reveling in his triumph after announcing
earlier that day his intention to defy a
grand jury subpoena he says he received
in the Russia investigation the former
Trump aide had spent the day conducting
a manic media blitz popping up on
multiple cable news programs granting
interviews to dozens of journalists and
hijacking the news cycle with car crash
procession of blustery sound bikes
legal experts were warning his failure
to cooperate with Muller's investigation
could put him in serious legal jeopardy
but none Berg was in a celebratory mood
so when I talked to number of months ago
he was always in a celebratory mood this
is a guy who's kind of manic he said can
you report this he says you have to
report this the champ champ does
whatever the f he wants the champ champ
apparently is a reference to one of his
favorite UFC fighters and apparently he
was it he was alternating between an
unalloyed bravado and a kind of meta
amusement so what exactly was he doing
what exactly what he was he doing
apparently the mystery of his
motivations had hovered over the day's
astonishing events theories attempting
to explain his bizarre behavior
proliferated quickly according to
Coppins some believed he's responding to
being caught in a genuine conspiracy
auditioning for immunity perhaps are
covering up crimes admitted and
committed by allies in the president's
orbit but here's it none Berg's own
explanation after being ordered to hand
over his past private correspondence
with several former Trump
he was sorting through his inbox Monday
morning and determined that complying
with the subpoena would be an
intolerable hassle he said after all I
have a life okay that is that is fully
possible but there is a question to be
asked okay let's assume that Santa
nunberg is borderline nuts let's say
that the guy is a kook which apparently
he is what's the media's obligation not
to put Kooks on TV what's the media's
obligation not to put crazy people on TV
because half the people in politics are
totally crazy let's say that I had told
you back in circle like 2012 that there
was some guy who's wandering around
saying things like the President of the
United States was born in Kenya let's
say that he was wandering around
commenting on Robert Pattinson 'he's
relationship with Kirsten Stewart let's
say that he was wandering around saying
weird things about reality TV and also
weird things about politics and just
sort of generally mouthing off and in
somewhat crazy fashion would you put him
on TV the answer's maybe put him on TV
because now he's the president of the
United States in other words we've had
some pretty crazy people in politics for
a while so well I'm ripping on the media
I'm not sure that it's fully justified
to rip on the media for putting this guy
on TV I will say I'm not sure the
treatment would have been the same if
you're an Obama official versus being a
trump official I also think that there's
a difference between people like Jake
Tapper or even our email we're putting
him on TV
and people like Karen Burnett if Erin
Burnett actually thought that he was
drunk if Erin Burnett actually thought
that this that that Sam Nunn Berg was a
loose cannon off his rocker
then that is irresponsible journalism
but it does raise the question of what
kind of journalistic ethics the media
have been using recently and the answer
is not very good you have a lot of
partisan hacks on both sides of the
aisle or either willing to cover for the
president or willing to slander the
president with anything that they can
get their hands on and if they think
that Sam Nunn Berg is gonna come out of
the woodwork and ramble on incessantly
about crazy things they will put him on
the air just for the sake of putting him
on the air which is not a good look it's
really not a good look for the media and
it's and you know they should be a
little bit more careful apparently who's
booked for like the Today show this
morning it's easy if you're Omarosa
apparently yeah but look some of the
responsibility here also falls on the
Trump campaign they really have to stop
hiring top men from the end of India and
Jones and the Raiders of the Lost Ark
right their top men are not top men and
sam nunn Berg is just more proof of that
okay so meanwhile in
sexuality continues to make people on
the left insanely stupid so overnight
literally over a 24-hour period there
were a bevy of anti right-wing
disruptions on campus so christina hoff
luck christina hoff sommers friend mine
the factual feminist she's professor she
was speaking about feminism and she was
speaking about the the failures of the
social justice warrior program and she
was shouted down is it a law school okay
so this is this was happening at Lewis
and Clark law school which is one of the
better schools in the country and a
coalition of student groups had demanded
that what they called known fascist
christina hoff sommers be no platform
meaning that they shouldn't allow her to
speak and they put out the Portland
National Lawyers Guild put out a
statement saying we are proud of our
student chapter for taking a concerted
stand against fascist racist and
misogynistic views being broadcasted on
campus the National Lawyers Guild boos
and Clarke choppers joined with the
minority Law Students Association black
Law Students Association women's law
caucus immigration student group Jewish
Law Society Latino Law Society outlaw
and Lewis and Clark young Democratic
Socialist of America to ask the
Federalist Society rescind their
invitation they did not they did not
rescind the invitation and and christina
hoff sommers showed up anyway I really
like Christina she is a charming woman
and not only is she charming she's also
quite intelligence and had a quite
intelligent that has a lot to say she is
not a fascist okay there's no evidence
that she's a fascist and the attempt to
boil down fascism to anything I don't
like is simply idiotic which is more
fascist christina hoff sommers coming
and speaking about the the lies of the
feminist movement or the people who are
suggesting that they should actually be
able to shut down her lecture by use of
force that seems a little more fascist
to me so here's a little bit of the
video when Christina started trying to
start her lecture last night at Lewis
and Clark law school
[Music]
[Applause]
okay nothing quite says bucking trends
like repeating verbatim word-for-word
what people are telling you to say
nothing really says that you're thinking
for yourself quite like repeating in
North Korean fashion exactly what your
dictator tells you to say pretty amazing
I love that the woman who's walking
around here with a jacket saying stay
woke
he's just standing at the front and
shouting at people and then according
Cristina what happened is that the
diversity officer from the university
came up to her and asked her to cut
short her lecture and go directly to Q&A
instead of finishing her lecture just
absolute class shown by the university
over at Lewis & Clark disgusting stuff
but not a shock I remember they tried to
do this to me over at University of
Wisconsin if I were Christina I
immediately would have done exactly what
I did at University of Wisconsin she's
got an entire white board behind her
that gives her the ability to create
some pretty fun visuals with the people
who are standing right there I remember
I wrote on the blackboard it was a
rising blackboard at University of
Wisconsin I wrote in very large letter
idiots with a look with an arrow
pointing to the people who are
protesting and so that was in all the
pictures which is kind of funny I would
recommend it to Christina that she do
that as well it's just it's asinine but
that wasn't the only place that this was
happening yesterday so my friend Jordan
Peterson he was speaking over in over in
Canada at I'm tremble which University
this was and while he was be is Queen's
University and while he was speaking
people started banging on the windows
trying to shatter the the windows at
this church I'm is happening in Grant
Hall I guess I'm not sure if it was a
church if it's just a lecture hall and
people started banging on the windows
people attempting to stop the lecture
they were followed by a bunch of violent
people afterward here's a little bit of
the video from Jordan Peterson's lecture
again this is all happening in the same
48-hour period just demonstrating to you
how intersectionality has made the left
completely insane
[Music]
okay so well done for the college where
is their security why is security not
removing those people why security not
preventing those people from disrupting
what sure the answer is because security
allows people to do all the sort of
stuff because they don't want to be seen
as repressive of the actual repressive
forces it's the same reason I get
shuttled to satellite campuses at
University of Minnesota it's the reason
they shot my lectures to the public at
University of Connecticut and University
of California Los Angeles and University
of California Berkeley it's the reason
why we have trouble at every campus
because the administrators are too
chicken bleep to actually stands up to
the violent people okay and it's not
just them it's not just that there was
another case of this last night as well
and I will tell you about that case and
I'll tell you more about the
intersectional failures of the left in
just a second first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Indo Chino
so nothing makes you look better than a
custom-made suit nothing right you're
going to instead a department store and
you buy one of these things off the rack
and then a tailor has to reverse
engineer it instead you should be
getting your suit made from scratch just
like James Bond
that's what endo Chino is for it's the
world's largest made-to-measure menswear
company they've been featured in major
publications including GQ Forbes and
Fast Company they make suits suits
shirts made to your exact measurements
for a fantastic fit and here's how it
works
they have showrooms all over the country
you can go there where they have one in
Los Angeles or you can shop online at
Indo Chino comm you pick your fabric you
choose your customizations you submit
your measurements actually a really fun
process I've done it myself my favorite
suit is a three-piece powder-blue suit
that's right
sometimes the shapiro gets creative with
his dress and I wear that to synagogue
it is it is one of my favorite suits and
it fits the best of any of my students
because it's custom made this week my
listeners can get any premium Enzo Chino
suit for just 379 bucks at ENSO Chino
calm when you enter Shapiro at checkout
that's Indo Chino calm enter Shapiro I
check out 50% off the regular price for
a made to measure premium suit and
shipping is free so it's Indo Chino calm
slow promo code Shapiro okay so again in
Sochi know ing OCH ino endo chino calm
promo code Shapiro and again any premium
suit 379 bucks and free shipping
it's an incredible deal for a suit
that's gonna fit you better than
anything else you're gonna be able to
get use that promo code Shapiro to make
sure you get the $379 deal ok so it
wasn't just Christina it wasn't just
Jordan Peterson it was also Yaron Brook
so yarn Brooke is an Objectivist
meaning that he is a devotee of ein Rand
I find his thought really interesting he
and I disagree about about some things
obviously because I'm not an Objectivist
I think that Iran is great on economics
and not great when it comes to extending
her philosophy to personal relationships
but in any case he was speaking at
King's College I guess and he in in
Britain and in antifoam AAB up and shut
him down so here's what that looked like
[Applause]
[Music]
hey then violence breaks out one of the
students who's doing the filming has
attacked just wonderful stuff according
to the examiner this is the London
examiner I believe the violent protests
also broke out around outside after
around 200 students were turned away
when King's College decided to prevent
an eye on students from attending the
event again King's College did exactly
what so many colleges have done to me
they've suggested that people should not
be allowed to attend from the outside
world students told the examiner they
believe King's College turned a blind
eye to the ante for members because they
disagreed with the content of the speech
but they couldn't legally prevent Yaron
Brook and Sark on as sargon of akkad is
kind of a YouTube figure from speaking
on campus students who waited outside
the auditorium became in mesh inner
protests the school knew was coming and
Antipa released smoke bombs and threw
punches students were in the line of
fire one student told the news
organisation quote I feel strongly the
university caved into the ante for
protesters they need to protect speech
and not prevent people from joining
peacefully they changed criteria just
2.5 hours prior to the event despite it
having been scheduled for months I'm
very disappointed in an institution a
top university in the world acting
cowardly like this okay and but this has
become obviously the thing the left does
now why is the left so angry christina
hoff sommers or jordan peterson or Yaron
Brook and sargon of akkad why why are
they so angry at these people well
because all of these people violate the
tenets of intersectionality
intersectionality is the philosophy it's
identity politics it's the philosophy
that says your identity as a person is
your group identity you're not an
individual you are a group identity so
you're a black guy you're not a person
with individual viewpoints and if you're
a black guy your viewpoint should be of
left because otherwise you're not truly
black if you're a Jewish person you must
be of the left because as we all know
Jews about Democrat and that means that
if you're Jewish and you're not of the
Democratic Left then you must not be a
good representative of Judaism you must
not be a good Jew and therefore we rip
away your intersectional identity ok the
foolishness of this obvious is pretty
obvious and pretty astonishing but
unfortunately it has infused the entire
left it really has infused a large
portion of the left identity politics
predominating over meaningful discourse
over meaningful discourse and it's not
just these idiotic students these Antipa
members attempting to shut down debate
on college campuses the most obvious
example it happened actually last night
so my good friend Bethany Mandel who
used to write over at comment
a magazine she writes for the
Federalists on occasion and Bethenny
does a podcast as well so Bethenny had
one of the worst childhood experiences
ever right so Bethenny grew up dirt poor
in a trailer park she heard her mom died
she had to pull the plug on her mom when
she was 16 her dad committed suicide
when he was when she was 19
her dad was a drug addict apparently and
all of this is to say that Bethenny's
life story is not exactly a bed of roses
she converted to Judaism and she married
my friend Seth they have a bunch of kids
really wonderful people
she wrote a piece for the New York Times
over the weekend I mean it came out
Monday in which she talked about her
experiences and why she owns a gun and
the reason she says she owns a gun is
because when she was growing up she was
living with her mom her dad had already
taken off and somebody legitimately they
were living I guess an apartment on the
second storey
some robber putting a ladder to her
window and attempted to climb it in her
window
right when she was a kid and her mom
walked in with a gun that she had with a
with a rifle that she had and pointed it
at the window and said to Bethenny move
aside or you're gonna get brains honey
basically and when the guy showed up at
the top of the window she said to him
you better run or I'm gonna shoot you
and that was the end of that and so
Bethenny said as I got a lot of Bethenny
had a lot of death threats in the last
election cycle she was not Pro Trump and
so she brought a gun in the aftermath of
that well Shannon Watts is a is a gun
control warrior Shannon watts is a
radical gun control advocate and and she
decided to attack Bethenny for being
white she said that Bethenny suffered
from white privilege so do we have some
of those tweets this is 14 so Shannon
Watts attacked Bethenny Mandel and and
what she said was this New York Times
paired this op-ed by a white woman based
on her anecdotes for fear and paranoia
instead of actual gun safety data with a
photo of a woman of color how dare the
New York Times suggest that women of
color and women who are white might have
common interests when it comes to having
a gun
we never mind that there's an actual
picture of a woman shopping for a gun
right there who's a woman of color
apparently according to Shannon Watts
that person doesn't exist but then she
says that Beth all Bethenny is a white
woman full of fear and paranoia not that
she had a personal experience is
somebody trying to break into her house
or not that she received death threats
Bethenny is just a typical white woman
and if she really were not
white and should understand the threat
that guns pose and then it gets even
worse right she actually tweeted out a
bunch of nastiness about Bethany she
suggested that Bethany was actually a
racist right Shannon Watts actually
suggested that Bethany was a racist from
wanting to protect herself from
neo-nazis which is just all class and
again all this comes down to is that
intersectional politics right all this
comes down to is is a nasty
intersectional politics because again
you know the Bethany's story has nothing
to do with her color but according to
Shannon white that is Shannon Watts that
is all that matters
she says that the problem with America
right now is that people are making gun
laws based on emotion not data and
Bethany replied I'm sorry you've been
have you not been promoting the Parkland
students emotions for the last two weeks
or are we only allowed to base decisions
on certain emotions and Shannon Watts
suggested quote your privilege in
feeling that a gun will make you safer
is in part because you are white CVC
data actually shows the opposite about
gun ownership so Bethany says a guy
tried to climb in my bedroom and kill me
when I was a kid and my mother scared
him off with the gun and Shannon
Watson's reply was you only care about
this because you are white and then
Bethany said I took my mom off life
support at sixteen and my father hang
himself when I was 19 and grew up in a
single-wide trailer in Northrop's
trailer park in upstate New York besides
that I've been truly hashtag blessed
right Shannon wasp replied quote again
your white skin makes you less likely to
be at risk as a gun owner regardless of
your hardscrabble background I guess you
don't believe in racism okay so suddenly
Bethany doesn't believe in racism
because she's actually been threatened
by a guy climbing in her window the
intersectionality here is just
astonishing
intersectionality again making people
stupid every single day and I'm gonna
give you another example of
intersectionality making people insane
and stupid in just a second first you're
gonna have to go over to Daly wire.com
and subscribe so for $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription to Daly wire calm
when you do you get the rest of our show
live to get the rest of the Michael
moles chill live to get the rest of the
Andrew Clavin show live you get them you
get to be part of the mailbag which we
are doing here on Friday and it'll be
great you'll gonna want to be part of it
so you'll get all of those glories for
$9.99 a month plus our next episode of
the conversation is coming up Tuesday
March 13th 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m.
Pacific featuring your favorite human me
ben shapiro subscribe today to be a part
of the conversation so I can answer your
questions in this hour-long live Q&A my
conversation will stream live on the
bench Shapiro Facebook page and The
Daily wire YouTube channel it will be
free for everyone to watch only
subscribers can ask the questions to ask
questions as a subscriber all you have
to do is log into our website daily wire
comm head over to the conversation page
to watch the live stream after that you
just start typing into that daily wired
chat box and I will answer questions as
they come in for an entire hour once
again subscribe right now get your
questions answered by me ben shapiro on
tuesday march 13th at 5:30 p.m. Eastern
2:30 p.m. Pacific and join the
conversation if you want to get all of
those things and the leftist ears hot or
cold tumblr the world famous never
duplicated tumblr $99 a year old do it
go over to daily wire.com become an
annual subscriber please it always helps
us it helps us bring you the show every
single day when you become a subscriber
so if you want it if you're asking how
you can help that's one way you can help
go over and subscribe to get all those
privileges and immunities as well if you
just want to listen later iTunes
SoundCloud Google Play stitcher YouTube
please subscribe looser review it always
helps we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
all righty so speaking of
intersectionality making people insanely
stupid so as I've been tracing over the
course of the last few weeks Louis
Farrakhan is one of the more disgusting
characters in American public life he is
the head of the Nation of Islam he's an
open anti-semite he calls Jews satanic
he suggests that white people are Devils
he is the worst of the worst of the
worst and a couple of the heads of the
women March a women's March are big fans
of his
they have been defended in turn by Linda
Sarsour who another anti-semite who has
defended Louis Farrakhan or at least the
people who defend Louis Farrakhan and
people who are associated with the
women's March could say ladies it's time
to it's time to cast out Louis Farrakhan
instead advocates of the women's March
say our intersectionality makes US
allies in other words yes I'm a Jew and
I'm a member of the women's March but
I'm not insulted by the fact that Louis
Farrakhan is backed by top members of
the women's March because we have common
interests our common interest is in
tearing down the patriarchy so I'm not
gonna speak up I'm not gonna say
anything about the nastiness inside my
own movement now I hate this kind of
stuff when it was identity politics of
the right I said so I don't like
tribalism
tribalism on the right suggested that
when the Trump campaign was making
common cause with the all right I was
totally okay because Hillary Clinton had
to be taken down and I said no that's
not okay it's not only counterproductive
politically it's immoral you can't make
light of the alt-right you can't pretend
these are nice people you can't pretend
that the actual anti-semites out there
are people who ought to be brought into
the fold because you share a common
cause with them that's intersectionality
identity politics of the right and it's
gross I was one of the lead advocates on
that score on the left however the same
people who were saying that the
alt-right was gross and Trump had to
throw them off which is correct are now
saying that the women's March is totally
fine they have no problem with
anti-semitism
even though top leaders of the women's
March are now obviously in league with
open anti-semites there's an article
over at the forward calm talking about
this talking about this unfortunate
tendency which has been largely ignored
by the mainstream media by the way Jake
Tapper CNN being lone exception so
there's a woman named um named Sophie
Elliman go on she's a passionate
feminist she's a she runs communications
for the women's March and now she has
ripped into a couple of these members of
the lemons Marsh
I'm tired of our movements not taking
anti-semitism seriously it's not okay
it's taking a toll on me and on all
Jewish people on the Left we are tired
and heartbroken okay and but what's
amazing is how people on the Left have
responded to that what's amazing is how
people on the Left have responded to the
fact that Tameka Mallory who is a member
of the women's March to top member the
women's March has repeatedly praised and
associated with Farrakhan participate in
a rally with him last week at which he
maligned two Jews as the spawn of Satan
she's a former executive director of
Reverend Al Sharpton's National Action
Network al Sharpton again another
notorious anti-semite who's again
featured in mainstream media on a repeat
basis Farrakhan is leading anti-semite
in the United States he's claimed that
Adolf Hitler was a very great man it's
not just Tameka Mallory there was
another woman who was associated with
the women's March who was involved he
talked about this in the last couple of
days so they went and asked over at
former calm a bunch of intersectional
leaders on the Left who were Jews about
this he can see how identity politics
Trump's everything but identity politics
doesn't actually mean standing up for
your identity as a Jew it means standing
up for the idea that you are a member of
a dispossessed class so here's one of
the funny things about being a member of
an identity group being a member of an
identity group doesn't mean that there's
any spent anything special about your
identity group the only thing about your
identity group that matters in identity
politics is that it is anti the quote
unquote establishment is that it seeks
to tear down the hierarchy that it seeks
to break apart the status quo so it
doesn't matter that there are
differences between black folks and Jews
on politics it doesn't matter there's a
difference between Muslims and Jews
certainly on politics so long as they
all claim common cause and tearing down
the structure they're all members of the
same group so this is why people are
constantly asking the question why is it
that folks on the Left seem so tolerant
of radical Muslims when radical Muslims
are totally anti-gay they're totally
anti women's rights they're totally anti
liberalism why is it that so many
members left like you'll see LGBT groups
match a marching arm and arm with people
who support Hamas why is that why is
that and the answer is because as member
of identity groups they don't actually
have solidarity within identity groups
against other identity groups the
purpose of the identity group is to band
together in this great cohesive unit of
the so-called dispossessed to fight
against the broader spectrum so radical
Muslims don't have anything in common
with the LGBT crowd but they do have
common cause in tearing down what they
see as America's terrible terrible
superstructure of racism and oppression
and so they will overlook the evils of
the other in orders that they can tear
down their allies of convenience and
allies of identity that's the that's the
idea here so Jill Jacobs who's just
gross she's executive director of true
there have been a call for Human Rights
rabbi Jill Jacobs who knows less about
Judaism than my four-year-old daughter
she says well Louis Farrakhan said is
disgusting inexcusable I don't think one
can dismiss the entire movement and
certainly not the entire progressive
world because of a statement by one
person or two people they imagine that
this were said about David Zook in the
all right let's say that there are a
bunch of members of the alt-right
associated with David Duke which they
have and let's say that somebody said
listen David Duke is just deplorable
he's disgusting he's awful but I really
had to slander the entire alright
because David Duke are you really gonna
do that and the answer is yeah kinda I
mean if you tolerate this stuff then you
become a party to it
Judy levy is executive director of the
Jewish Council on urban affairs and she
made excuses for it as well she said
people don't always express themselves
on every single issue in ways that we
would that we would be comfortable but
it's really important that when we share
values who work together to raise up the
urgent issues that we all face and there
it is in a nutshell identity politics is
about the common cause it is not about
actually standing up for your identity
group even as Sharon brous who spoke at
the 2017 women's March she is at least
attempting to do something where she
said there's no room in a multi-faith
multi-ethnic coalitional movement for
anti-semitism homophobia or transphobia
in a big tent movement there has to be
room for disagreement but certain core
values must stand at the forefront yeah
except that these women are not going to
be tossed out Linda Sarsour is still
being cheered and Linda Sarsour by the
way is not only being cheered inside the
women's March when the Sarsour is being
cheered over at UConn so it turns out
that she's supposed to speak at
University of Connecticut and when she
speaks the University of Connecticut she
is she is not going to have to have
tremendous security nor are the students
being offered preliminary counseling so
you'll recall then when I spoke at
University of Connecticut the general
public was barred you'll also recall
that the administration sends out a full
letter to the student body suggesting
that if they need a preliminary
counseling because I was gonna say
something so terrible that that would be
available Linda Sarsour has his iana
scan not be feminist Linda Sarsour has
repeatedly supported terrorists when the
Sarsour is one
the worst people in American politics
she is a radical and yet she is being
treated as royalty at UConn well I was
treated as basically a David Duke type
which is precisely the opposite of the
truth when it comes to me versus Linda
Sarsour so pretty amazing but again all
that matters is the identity politics
and it's infused the entire Democratic
Party it's one of the reasons that are
looking at candidates like Kamala Harris
it's the reason that are looking at Cory
Booker it's the reason that are looking
at hooli and Castro as opposed to
looking at you o Biden the good news for
Republicans is that the more the
Democrats engage in this broader
identity politics movement the more they
engage in intersectional
intersectionality which was mentioned by
the way at the Oscars by Ashley Judd
talk about intersectionality the more
the Left tries to suggest that they are
a coalition of the dispossessed fighting
the the great power structure the more
Americans think I don't want any part of
these people I don't want anything to do
with these people the left is alienating
more people with high-density politics
then it's drawing it now they're banking
on the idea that the changing
demographics of the United States are
going to create an intersectional
majority coalition but I don't think
that's the case because again I think
people are individuals not members of
identity groups and I think people will
turn away if they're treated as
individuals from the stupidity and
malice of the intersectional movement
alright so in other news I wanted to I
wanted to point today is normally a day
when we would do deconstructing the
culture but instead of doing
deconstructing the culture at the end of
the show I want to point out a bit of a
controversy over the bachelor so the I
mentioned the other day a very funny
show called the good place and sound
Network TV I think you can also get it
on Netflix I don't even know a channel
the time because I cut the cord a long
time ago but the good place has a joke
in it where they're talking about people
who get into heaven and the people who
get into heaven are apparently the
people who do not watch The Bachelor
like this is one of the actual criterias
that if you watch The Bachelor you have
emotional investment in The Bachelor it
makes you a bad person well I think that
that's probably true so ABC I'm sure
that would good people who watch The
Bachelor but they are wasting their time
and their life force so last night on
The Bachelor you wonder why our country
got so stupid you wonder why our country
has turned into an emotional basket case
maybe it's because we watch reality TV
and we think it's actual reality and
then we invest obviously fictionalized
stories with the power of true human
emotions so The Bachelor apparel I
hadn't watched one
minute of the bachelor of the season so
forgive me if I slightly botched the
story apparently the bachelor had picked
one woman as the woman who was going to
marry and then it turns out that he
divorced her and he didn't divorce her
he broke up with her after they were
engaged and got together with the second
place finisher know what I would say
about the second place finisher is have
you no pride woman have you no gumption
if a guy throws you over for another
girl and then he leaves that other girl
back for you have you no sense of
self-worth that you would go with that
guy but here's what it looked like on
The Bachelor and of course this is
exploitative television in every way
these people signed up for it so it's
hard to feel terrible for them but it
really is kind of yucky that so many
people find meaning in what is obviously
stagecraft
to more humans for yourself if you want
me just to go go
was it truly the most shocking finale in
bachelor history in a three-hour special
episode Monday night viewers saw our
elion Dyke jr. break up with Lauren
Byrne opposed to Becca kufran I choose
you today but I choose you every day
from here on out only to dump kufran in
a raw painful unedited scene
you said me he told her he wanted to try
again with Lauren and his help the
further along we got the further I
started drifting away from the
possibility of trying it again with her
relationship and this may only be the
start of the Fallout franchise favorite
Becca Martinez revealed Monday night
that the 36 year old had been sending
her a few private messages they seemed
harmless until that is messaging super
duper classy SuperDuper classy and then
all of America gets invested in this
kind of tawdry nonsense who wonder why
with reality TV star ended up being
president okay just a little bit of data
for those of you who are fans of The
Bachelor in 20 seasons of The Bachelor
12 men have actually popped the question
on air however of those 20 of those 20
seasons two of the couples are still
together one is married okay that is a
worse ratio than people who are going
down to the bar getting drunk and
hitting on people that is an awful
awful ratio case it's a little bit
better on the Bachelorette apparently
the Bachelorette
I guess that they've had a couple of
successes so Season seven they had a
success Season nine they had a success
and Season eleven in season 12 I guess
people are still together but it's not
it's like 50% so the the notion that any
of this is real is just absurd of course
it's not real but when we get caught up
in investing our emotions in reality TV
which is all being produced behind the
scenes but my mama is a reality TV
producer okay my mom has done this stuff
I've watched for all footage of reality
TV shows before it is nothing like what
appears on television they can make
virtually anything appear interesting
and fascinating reality TV is not but it
just demonstrates once and for all that
there are a lot of people who are who
are finding value in in relationship
stuff that has nothing do with
relationship so I was asked a question
recently that at a college I think is at
University of Minnesota about whether a
leftist should date a conservative now
what I said is if you're dating for
marriage which is supposedly what the
bachelor or the Bachelorette are about
if you're dating for those things the
first thing you should be talking about
is values has there ever been an episode
of the bachelor or the Bachelorette
where people actually talked about
values or they actually talked about
what they wanted their lives to look
like or is it more just will jet set off
to the most romantic location and then
we will hang out together until we fall
in love and when we're really sexy
outfits and go in the jacuzzi together
okay again all of this is really dumb
none of it is built for relationships
but this is what relationships week on
and then we're surprised when people
imitate what they see on TV and ignore
values and relationships no wonder
people are not sticking together they're
not sticking together because we have a
stupid idea of how adult relationships
are supposed to work largely promulgated
by the media okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like since we did the the
good place yesterday I figured we'll do
some heaven themed stuff this week so
underrated movie what dreams may come
with Robyn ones the visuals in this
movie are really what make it
interesting
Robyn well anytime you watching Robin
Williams movies really sad watch Robin
Miller Williams movies now obviously
because what happened to him but it's
what do you do himself but it's um the
movie is is quite moving and I think
that it works Max von Sydow is in it
here's a little bit of the trailer
the moment that comes for everyone
[Music]
has come for Chris Nielsen you died
Chris if Heaven is a place where you
know only joy
screwed up I'm in dog heaven you're
creating an entire world here from your
imagination from anything you want where
you feel no more fear I'm gonna drop
can't you're already dead and anything
you can imagine
is real
could you let go
you left behind the movie is the movie
is actually quite moving and it really
works one of the things about Robin
Williams as an actor as you can see the
demand was a truly troubled individual
and you can always see there's a sort of
pain behind his eyes and in this movie
it really works for him
so check out what dreams may come worth
while watching okay other things that I
like Nikki Haley my spirit animal at the
UN that's issues speaking at AIPAC
yesterday and she talked about Israel
and the United Nations the United
Nations of course is the most Eisley of
actual life I here is Nikki hailey
talking about the UN at the UN and
throughout the UN agencies Israel does
get bullied it gets bullied because the
countries that don't like Israel are
used to being able to get away with it
well just like when I was that little
girl in South Carolina that just doesn't
sit well with me Jerusalem is the
capital of Israel that's a fact and
President Trump had the courage to
recognize that fact when others would
not the United Nations spends half of
its time attacking only one country we
will not accept it any longer yeah good
for nikki Haley this is one of the best
things about the Trump administration
it's one area where they bucked foreign
policy conventional wisdom and they've
done really well with it okay time for
some things that I hate okay so
apparently the the hatred of guns is so
strong now that the dating app bumble
has announced that it will ban profile
photos with guns in them in response to
the shooting at Parkland a statement on
the bumble website said the company will
now moderate all photos for the presence
of guns excluding users who are in
military or law enforcement uniforms in
their photos so if you are a gun packing
woman then you cannot be on bumble with
that picture they also announced they
would donate a hundred thousand dollars
to the March for our lives that anti gun
violence at March organized by the
survivors of the Parkland shooting again
is any of that worthwhile is any of that
going to stop violence with guns of
course not it's all virtues signaling
but so much of corporate culture has now
become virtue signaling that it's it's
actually really troubling it's one of
the reasons by the way that you are
seeing a change in the actual way that
news is done the way that the news
industry is done so if you look at
Facebook Facebook is now changing its
algorithm YouTube has been changing you
say algorithm they're downgrading
anything that has mild
controversial contents they're
attempting to weed out stuff that gets
people excited or gets people irritated
or confronts them with news they don't
want to see because advertisers are
getting blowback from people on the
supposedly or at least advertisers don't
want to be associated with controversial
opinions okay the reason this is a real
problem is because what this does is it
actually ensures that people are going
to go to their own bubbles because the
way that the model works on places like
Facebook or YouTube is their ad
supported models so you know if you get
our show on YouTube for example then
YouTube may play an ad beforehand or
then ad monetize one of our videos they
may take the ads off beforehand well if
they do that to people who are totally
reliant on ad support if they that's a
dave rubin for example then that forces
people to give money to rubin to
subscribe to reuben in order to get that
content and what that means is that dave
Reubens crowd of people from whom he is
drawing money is going to be smaller
than normally would be so at ARS B so
it's even Crowder's B so with Joe
Rogan's B anybody who gets D monetized
on a regular basis is going to have to
rely on a subscription model
subscription models are by nature opt-in
models that means that people who are
not familiar with the contents are not
going to subscribe and that means that
if you're familiar with the New York
Times you're never gonna see an opposing
viewpoint if you're familiar with daily
wire you're never going to see an
opposing viewpoint it actually ensures
that the bubbles are strengthened so
corporate weakness in these areas is
really bad for the country and it's one
of the reasons why Media Matters has
done such awful work in trying to go
after advertisers simply for advertising
on sites that carry messages the demand
that they may not like I think it's a
really dangerous business in the in
which they are engaging okay other
things that I that I hate so worthwhile
noting the West Virginia teachers strike
is apparently still continuing that they
were talking about settling it this
morning I'm not sure if they have
finally settled it or not it's in its
second week this strike is illegal so
basically a bunch of teachers in West
Virginia are striking against the state
of West Virginia in order to get higher
pay I don't like public sector unions
because they're striking against the
taxpayer this is why public sector
unions should be illegal it should not
be legal for people to strike against
the taxpayer can you imagine the cops
striking against the taxpayer just not
gonna do our job were just gonna walk
off okay they did the state should have
to pay whatever it is that people are
willing to take but this is why unions
that actually get together and band
together and then have people walk out
in order to deprive the taxpayers of
services that we are owed for the tax
money that we are paying
are really really bad now do I blame the
teachers who are members of the unions
no but I do blame the but I do blame the
Union itself and the state for engaging
in this in this sort of negotiation they
should have filed a legal case an
injunction against the Union on on this
and they should have gone back to what
West Virginia's law is which is
right-to-work they should have just gone
to individual teachers and hired the
individual teachers back at prices that
they are willing to pay and prices that
the teachers are willing to work for
okay we'll be back here tomorrow with
all the latest i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing